let's go next to our caller from the 2:8
one area code who's calling today from
two eight one
hey David this is Kira from Houston
hey Jarrod what's going on so I'm a
first-time caller and I voted for Bernie
in 2016 in a primary okay and one of the
reasons why I'm moving off of him
because I've been thinking not
necessarily about his electability but
what he could actually do he got elected
hmm so let's let's take the best-case
scenario he gets a House and Senate
that's democratic yep we know like a lot
of Dems opposed Medicare for all and you
already mentioned they can't pay finance
reform yeah and what I'm worried about
he gets elected he gets pushed back five
moderate Democrats progressives get
depressed and then the Republicans have
sweep back in 2022 because the Democrats
are in fighting so much and I just
wanted to know do you think if you were
to get elected could he kind of keep
that Democratic would they wouldn't send
it could he keep it even United so let's
take it let's make it less hypothetical
because even in your hypothesis there's
already things you're mentioning that
aren't going to happen so let me give
you an example the Senate is not going
Democratic in 2020 unless I am
incredibly missing something so the idea
that in his first two years Bernie will
have the House and Senate not going to
happen now as far as 2022 typically a
new president has their first midterm
not go their way everything is kind of
different right now and the 2022 Senate
map actually favors Democrats so let's
take the conversation in a slightly
different direction which is you are
given that you are right that for
example not every Democrat is on board
with Medicare for all anyway what is the
benefit of having a president who wants
Medicare for all versus a president like
Joe Biden who wants to like tweak
Obamacare and add a public option and
the answer is you often end up
unfortunately this is sort of how it
works you often end up in a sort of
middle-of-the-road position between what
the party in power wants in the middle
with what the party in power wants so
what I can tell you is the following if
Bernie is the president and Democrats
have the Senate and Democrats have the
house it's still very plausible that we
don't get Medicare for all
but whatever we end up negotiating to is
going to be way better than what we will
get if Joe Biden is president right so
that's my approach and everyone you're
saying is correct but we're still way
better off yeah that makes sense
I think it's just like I just think
about the whole no middle ground I'm
kind of concerned that a lot of Bernie
supporters would not even accept that
even if he were to move if he moves
anywhere well it's not going to be up to
them ultimately right I mean we we vote
to elect the president Trump did a whole
bunch of stuff he didn't tell his
supporters he was going to do at a
certain point it's like listen they
might not like it but ultimately Bernie
is gonna get whoever as president will
get whatever is closest to what they
want that they can get at the time and
that's kind of the way politics works
okay thank you
all right great to hear from you
appreciate the phone call let's take a
quick break if you were holding don't
hang up don't hang up if you're holding
because we will go right back to the
phones after this